Um zum eigentlichen Thema zurückzukommen, von den Wolfram-Elektronen und irgendwelchen Flugzeugen und so, wir waren ja eigentlich bei autonom sich bewegenden Geräten, bei Drohnen. Um mal wieder zum eigentlichen Thema zurückzukommen, gibt es da, oder in dieser Roboterwelt, gibt es da schon Fälle, wo es in irgendeiner Art von Rechtsprechung gab?
Also es gab halt diesen Fall, den Steini gerade angesprochen hat. Diese RoboDoc-Systeme waren halt automatische Hüftgelenk, Operationsroboter, wo Leute hinterher einfach massive Schäden hatten, weil da offensichtlich entweder ein Software-Bug gab oder ein Hardware-Fehler, das war mir jetzt nicht mehr so ganz klar. Und die haben halt erstmal Recht bekommen. Also zwar aber einfache Produkthaftung. Also sie haben, so wurde gesagt, es handelte sich um eine defekte, kaputte medizinische Hardware, die ihnen das Leben versaut hat. Und dafür haben sie halt irgendwie Schande dazu gesprochen bekommen. Und da wurden halt aber interessante Fragen nicht geklärt. Also ist jetzt halt der Betreiber mehr zuständig oder mehr der Hersteller. Das haben sie dann halt irgendwie mit großen Schandersatzzahlungen gelöst. Aber solche komplexen Technikfälle treten halt immer wieder aus. Auch zum Beispiel bei Industrieanlagen. Also Industrieanlagen gehen häufiger als man denkt durch Softwareprobleme kaputt. Da fährt dann halt irgendwie irgendein Prozessparameter hoch oder ein Sensor geht fritte und wird nicht richtig ausgelesen.
Und irgendein autonom fahrender Gabelstapler. Und davon gibt es mittlerweile richtig, richtig, richtig viele Krachtanhalte ins Hochregallager und die ganze Geschichte puttelt zusammen.
Im günstigsten Fall stehst du einfach an 50 Liter Frittierfett. Aber ihr seht schon, die Problematik ist relativ komplex und noch nicht mal im Ansatz irgendwie durchdacht. Deswegen machen wir auch diese Sendung hier, das Chaosradio, um mal so ein bisschen auf dieses Thema hinzuweisen. Und im Zweifelsfall könnt ihr euch auch gerne am 20.9. nach Niederfino bewegen. Dafür nehme ich die Motodrone. Fino-Ford. Niederfino ist auf der anderen Seite.
Auf dem alten Militärflugplatz.
Klar, eine Drohne muss man auf dem Flugplatz fliegen lassen.
Ja klar, logisch.
Ich würde wetten, dass Axel dann auch da sein wird.
Unter www.motodrohnen.de kann man sich da auch nochmal alle Informationen abholen.
Danke Axel.
Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Chaosradio 138 mit Frank Rieger, mit Steini, mein Name ist Jakob Kranz, wir reden über Drohnen. Wir haben jetzt eine Menge geredet, lass uns kurz ein bisschen Musik hören, oder? Die Vos aus England, Olympic Airways, Chaosradio 138, kurz nach 11, Mittwochabend, Steinig, Frank Krieger, mein Name ist Jakob Kranz, wir reden über Drohnen, haben wir jetzt also schon eine ganze Stunde gemacht, wir haben ein bisschen erklärt, wo die Dinge eigentlich herkommen, wir haben erklärt, was man damit machen kann, wer vor allen Dingen damit was machen. Also zum einen haben wir festgehalten, dass die Rechtsprechung oder die Gesetzeslage dafür noch überhaupt nicht ausreichend ist, wenn irgend so ein Ding unkontrolliert irgendwo vom Himmel fällt oder wo dagegen fliegt, was dann passiert, wer denn da irgendwie für den Schaden aufkommt.
Ja, also der, sagen wir mal, dieser ganze Raum der Verantwortlichkeit hängt halt sehr davon ab, wo diese Dinge eingesetzt werden. Also wenn wir jetzt mal annehmen, zum Beispiel wir fahren damit einfach durch die Gegend, es wird sehr einfach, also treffen wir auf einem Fußgänger oder auf ein anderes Auto, kann man sich das sehr einfach vorstellen. Kann man möglicherweise regeln wie ein Auto, aber wenn nehmen wir an, es handelt sich zum Beispiel um, wie gesagt, zum Beispiel diese Hüftgelenks-OP-Roboter, über die wir gerade gesprochen haben, ich hab gerade nochmal nachgeguckt, diese Firma hat einfach mal Insolvenz angemeldet. Die hatten halt irgendwie ein paar hundert Klagen am Hals in den USA. Und haben gesagt, können wir nichts machen, gehen wir mal insolvent. Und die Opfer standen dann im Wesentlichen nur mit so einer Minimalentschädigung aus irgendeinem Entschädigungsfond da. Und das ist natürlich kein befriedigender Zustand. Also die Verluste wurden halt vergesellschaftet in diesem Fall.
Womit wir bei dem Thema sind, was auch für den Chaos Computer Club und im Chaos Radio immer wieder auftaucht, nämlich die Freude an der technischen Entwicklung und an das Vortreiben der technischen Entwicklung und auf der anderen Seite natürlich auch irgendwie das Gefühl der Verantwortung, die man in dem Moment übernehmen muss, mal an technischen Geräten, welcher Art oder Art bastelt und diese weiter treibt.
Ja genau, also diese Verantwortung ist natürlich so ein Ding, was uns umtreibt. Also auf der einen Seite ist es natürlich so, dass man sagen kann, okay, sollten wir denn so eine Technologie anfassen, die momentan primär militärischen oder Überwachungsaspekte hat, auch wenn es halt einen Höllen Spaß macht, ist es dann richtig damit umzugehen, denen da den Stand des Wissens voranzutreiben oder sollte man eher sagen, wir lassen das lieber, wir fassen das nicht an, weil das ist eher böse. Also die Ansicht gibt es auch.
Sonst machen wir es noch besser und dann können die bösen Leute noch schlimmere Sachen damit machen.
Du bastelst ja, du bist ja richtig drin.
Wie siehst du das? Ich stehe auf dem Standpunkt, ich kann nur darüber reden, was ich verstehe und ich stehe auf dem Standpunkt, die Ideen, die guten Ideen, die kommen an vielen Orten gleichzeitig auf der Welt einfach, weil der Stand des Wissens da ist und weil sich eine Idee immer aus den Myriaden vorhergehender Ideen ergibt, fast schon zwangsläufig. Also deswegen bin ich auch so komplett gegen das Urheberrecht, weil letztlich ist das nicht meine Idee gewesen, die ich da hatte, sondern das ist die eine zusätzlich zu den 400 Trillionen Ideen, die von der ersten Gedankesleistung eines intelligenten Wesens bis heute nötig waren, über Feuerrad und die ganze Geschichte letztlich dazu zu führen, dass mir die Grundlage gegeben war, diese eine zusätzliche, fast schon zwangsläufige Idee oben drauf zu packen, aus der was angeblich scheinbar neu ist, völlig neu ist wurde, was ja gar nicht der Fall ist. Das heißt, diese Ideen entstehen sowieso. Machen wir uns nichts vor, es gibt bessere Drohnen als das, was wir heute bauen können. Wir haben die Möglichkeit, wir können die auch nicht wieder einfach wegmachen, wir können nur drüber reden, welche Verantwortung haben wir.
Man kann sie nicht mehr ignorieren.
Man kann sie nicht ignorieren. Sie werden irgendwann... Da oben, wenn ich nachts in den Himmel gucke, da fliegen sie ja zu Haufen, nennen sich Satelliten, ist im Prinzip genau das gleiche, gucken in meinen Garten. Tag wie Nacht, wenn die wollen.
Und die Dinge, womit wir diese Anfang der Sendung auch schonmal, was wir schonmal angeschnitten haben, es ist ja eben nicht nur jetzt ein von militärischen Organisationen oder militärischen Entwicklungen gebautes Ding, sondern du kannst für 700 Euro dir eine Drohne zusammen basteln und damit ist es ein ganz normaler Alltag.
Gut, dass man das jetzt kann, da muss man aufpassen, da sind wir jetzt nicht ganz unschuldig dran. Bis dato kosteten die halt so 10.000 bis 20.000 Euro. Und dann hab ich leichtfertigerweise vor zwei Jahren auf dem Chaos-Kongress mal behauptet, dass die sich für unter 1.000 Euro bauen lassen. Und dann gab es halt gleich zwei Teams, die das dann innerhalb eines Jahres, innerhalb eines halben Jahres auch realisiert hatten.
Daniel Düsentrieb, die sagen, die machen was.
Die sich da wirklich angestachelt fühlen. Ich glaube, Ingo und Holger haben vorher schon dran gebaut. Es passte aber, wie schon gesagt, die Ideen kommen an vielen Ecken gleichzeitig. Es passte wieder Arsch auf den Topf. Ein halbes Jahr später hatten wir die Dinge für unter 500 Euro am Start. Da sind sie nun und nun sind sie nicht gut genug.
Wenn ich mal den Advokat des Diabolos spielen darf, nur kurz vertrete ich meine Meinung, aber ich probiere es mal ein bisschen zu produzieren. Was man natürlich damit tut, ist ein Personalpool für die Leute schaffen, die halt militärische Drohnen bauen und die Sachen halt sehr viel billiger machen. Also man ist halt schon dabei, eine Industrie zu fördern, die im Wesentlichen gerade erstmal von militärischen und Überwachungssystemen lebt.
Das sieht die Firma Microdrone völlig anders.
Und man demokratisch... na wieso? Ich meine die Mikrokopter...
Ne die Mikrokopter, ja die Microdrone, das kommerzielle Unternehmen, die finden das total nicht gut. Also das habe ich da auch schon zu hören bekommen, wir würden hier Arbeitsplätze vernichten, wie es ist damals. Und dass das natürlich nicht so ist, haben die vielleicht mittlerweile auch verstanden. Ich hoffe das. Aber es ist jetzt schon nicht so... Also klar, was wir damit fördern, ist das Interesse an dieser Thematik. Und natürlich stimmt das. Das erweitert den Pool der Menschen, die sich damit beschäftigen. So, keine Frage. Das schafft aber auch eben einen bezahlbaren Preis, sodass eben nicht nur erlesene Kreise plötzlich imstande sind, sich da eine Flotte anzulegen, Ihre Nachbarn zu beobachten. Ja zum Beispiel, aber mindestens Greenpeace mal imstande ist, beim nächsten G8-Gipfel statt mit Schlauchbooten mit 400 Drohnen anzukommen. Und irgendeine wird es schon schaffen.
Also man kann das halt irgendwie eigentlich nicht schwarz-weiß betrachten, wie sie es jetzt schon. Also es ist halt wie immer bei Technologie-Entwicklung, man kann sich natürlich auf den Standpunkt stellen und sagen, okay, man fasst das Thema nicht an, weil man sich die Finger nicht schmutzig machen möchte.
Wenn du es nicht machst, macht es jemand anders.
Das ist so offensichtlich, dass man darüber eigentlich nicht diskutieren braucht. Für mich ist es halt wichtig, zu verstehen, was da passiert, welche Technologien an den Horizont des Machbaren kommen, wie billig die werden und wohin die Reise da geht. Deswegen finde ich, dass es unterstützen wird. Es gibt andere Leute, die sagen, wir sollten lieber die Finger davon lassen, wir sollten nicht noch fördern und featuren. Aber wie gesagt, das ist halt ein kontroverses Thema. Mich würde mal interessieren, wie die Hörer das sehen, ob ihnen diese Entwicklung Sorge macht, dass plötzlich lauter fliegende Kameras geben wird und jeder, die haben kann oder sich für rum so weit hinstellen können, dergleichen Dinge mehr.
Also Frage an euch, 03317097110, macht es euch sorgen, dass die technische Entwicklung soweit ist, dass die fliegende, unbebandte Überwachungskamera mittlerweile irgendwann auch vor eurem Fenster sein wird oder sagt ihr, es ist doch super, wenn die Technik sich weiter entwickelt. Das wäre schön, wenn ihr da euren Senf dazugeben möchtet, 0331 70 97 110. Die erste am Telefon ist Uli, die glaube ich uns noch ein bisschen aus diesem Versicherungsloch rausholen will.
Ja, hallo.
Ach du bist ein Ulrich, Uli.
Ja, genau.
Ich dachte, okay, tut mir leid.
Ja, was diesen Aspekt angeht, möchte ich eigentlich nur Folgendes dazu sagen. Die Problematik aus versicherungstechnischer Sicht liegt für meinen dafür weniger darin begründet, dass jetzt sich die Frage stellt, wer hat versagt oder wer hat einen Fehler respektive einer Unterlassung begangen. Sondern die Problematik liegt für mich eigentlich darin, dass diese Drohnen, die einen echten Schaden anrichten können, sprich militärische Drohnen oder Überwachungsdrohnen, von hohertlicher Seite betrieben werden. Und wenn du dir mal anschaust, wie die Haftung staatlicher Stellen, das hat jetzt gar nichts mit deutschen staatlichen Stellen zu tun, auf internationaler Ebene sieht das ähnlich aus, wie die aussieht im Vergleich zur Haftung von Privatpersonen, dann merkst du recht schnell, dass der Geschädigte dahingehend in den Arsch gekniffen ist.
Aber wenn wir jetzt mal nicht die militärischen nehmen, die waren ja, also wir reden ja schon von der privaten Nutzung.
Ja, bei der privaten Nutzung ist das relativ einfach. Hier haftet die Haftpflichtversicherung des Betreibers.
Bist du Versicherungsprofi eigentlich?
Ja, ich bin Versicherungsmakler.
Ah, okay, das ist klar.
Das ist relativ einfach. Wenn du da mit deiner Fernbedienung oder wie auch immer deine Drohne fliegen lässt und die rauscht beim Nachbarn ins Wohnzimmerfenster, ist das ein klassischer Fall erstmal für deine Privathaftpflicht. Und wenn du jetzt der Meinung bist, das ist halt deswegen passiert, weil die Software einen Bug hatte, dann hast du rein theoretisch die Möglichkeit über die sogenannte Durchgriffshaftung, die Produkthaftpflicht des Herstellers in Anspruch zu nehmen. Das Problem ist einfach, du müsstest halt die Beweisführung darlegen, dass das wirklich aufgrund dieses Software-Bugs passiert ist.
Und dann sind wir wieder beim Punkt, den wir in dieser Sendung ansprechen. Ich will wissen, wie so ein Ding funktioniert.
Genau, du willst wissen, wie so ein Ding funktioniert. Und wir sind außerdem bei dem großen Punkt, wo sitzt der Hersteller? Ist der Hersteller wirklich derjenige, welcher derhaftbar ist? Es könnte ja auch sein, dass das Ding irgendwo in Taiwan zusammengelötet worden ist und irgendein Importeur, der in den Niederlanden sitzt, hat es importiert. Hat ja seinen Namen als Label draufgebabt. Das gilt als sogenannter Quasi-Importeur. Da will ich jetzt gar nicht ins Detail gehen. Das wird einmal zu kompliziert.
Das Problem eskizziert sich jetzt schon mal ganz grob. Also das hätten wir geklärt mit der Versicherung.
Das ist absolut kein Thema. Das war ja schon vor Drohnen der Fall, als man irgendwelche Flugmodelle fliegen liest. Also da ist an sich die Problematik nicht zu sehen. Was die Frage angeht, wegen der technischen Entwicklung. Also die Technik wird sich weiter entwickeln, ob uns das jetzt gefällt oder nicht. Und wir leben ja nun mal nicht irgendwie auf dem Planet oder auf der Insel der Glücksseligen. Das heißt, wenn das bei uns passiert, dann passiert das halt außerhalb unserer Landesgrenzen. Maßgeblich ist für meinen Geschmack eigentlich eher die Frage, was machen wir mit dieser Technologie? Missbrauchen wir sie für irgendwelche Schweinereien? Oder nutzen wir sie für sinnvolle Zwecke? Und was die Überwachungsproblematik angeht, also wer dich überwachen will, der konnte es auch in der Vergangenheit tun. Da musst du wahrscheinlich einen weitaus höheren Personalaufwand betreiben. Das haben uns ja die Herrschaften vom MFS über Jahrzehnte deutlich demonstriert, was da alles möglich ist. Und da sind wir wieder bei einem Punkt, wofür setzt sich die Technologie ein? Wofür die damals vielleicht 50 IEMs gebraucht haben? Das könntest du heute mit moderner Kommunikations-Elektronik mit einer Person bewirkt bleiben. Aber deswegen die Weiterentwicklung der Technologie zu verdammen, das hier dich definitiv für den falschen Weg.
Guter Ansatz, danke dir.
Bitte, danke schön. Schönen Abend noch.
Wir haben noch einen Anrufer und zwar Hannes, der kommt mit einer ganz spannenden Frage um die Ecke. Hallo Hannes. Hallo, wie alt bist du nun weg? Also noch nicht so im Hyper-Programmierer und Nerd-Alter.
Es fängt gerade an. Ich bin bei den Programmiersprachen schon mal reingeschnuppert. Ich bin tatsächlich auch so ein bisschen im Modellbau interessiert und so und mich beschäftigt ist jetzt schon länger die Frage auch, was man machen kann bei solchen Drohnen, um die quasi, also wenn diese Geschichte, wenn jetzt so ein Ding über dir schwebt, was machst du dann so? Und du kannst natürlich schön winken und so, aber mir ist irgendwie eingefallen, also einmal so Störsender, aber wenn die jetzt autonom fliegen, dann bringen ja Störsender so richtig auch nichts mehr. Also ja, keine Ahnung, ihr habt ganz am Anfang der Sendung, deswegen rufe ich auch an, mal kurz angesprochen, dass ihr da mal zu kommen wollt und da dachte ich, ich stoße jetzt einfach mal an.
Also die Frage, was kann man denn tun? Also da hängen natürlich wieder viel von den technischen Details ab, also eine gute Möglichkeit, die man nur gegen Drohnen verwenden sollte, aber sicherlich keinesfalls gegen Mimantel-Luftfahrzeuge ist, die Kamera im Laser zu blenden. Da reicht einfach auch ein dickerer Laserpointer, so einer von den grünen irgendwie 10mW-Dingern, die irgendwie machen doch irgendwie schon einen hinreichenden starken Lichtpunkt, wie gesagt, auf gar keinen Fall gegen Mimantel-Luftfahrzeuge machen, das hochgradig strafbereingegangenen Luftverkehr entwirkt und mehreren Jahren Knast geahndet zurecht.
Wie so was passiert dann?
Du kannst halt den Piloten blenden. Und wie gesagt, solche Hemmungen muss man halt gegen Drohnen nicht haben.
Aber wenn da kein Pilot drin sitzt, wie soll ich denn? Da kann ich auch keinen blenden.
Dann ist die Kamera.
Die geht dann nicht mehr.
Die geht dann halt nicht mehr.
Die hat dann überall schwarze, hektische Flecken.
Genau, oder hellgrüne oder was auch immer. Das ist ein sehr effektiver Weg, der auch, denke ich mal, nicht illegal ist. Nee, würde mir jetzt gar nicht irgendwie so illegal sein sollte. Wenn man sich dann halt natürlich noch ein bisschen weiter beschäftigt, kann man natürlich seine eigene Drohne starten und damit die andere Drohne abdrängen oder zum Absturz bringen. Das ist sicherlich auch eine Methode, die man sicherlich nicht über bewohnten Gebieten machen sollte.
Ja, vielleicht sollten wir zur nächsten Motodrohne dann einen Dogfight machen oder so irgendwas, wie man mal... Also das Problem wird real. Ich hatte das auf dem Kongress auch schon gesagt. Ich sehe von meinem geistigen Auge irgendwie drei Bohlen-Drohnen gegen 20 Paparazzi-Drohnen. Also das wird kommen, die Bohlen-Villa wird dann ständig von irgendwelchen Dingen umschwirrt, die dann halt immer mal wieder landen, sich automatisch aufladen, wieder losfliegen. Auch eine mögliche Challenge, wie lande ich dann automatisch auf einer Ladestation? Und ständig ist so ein Ding in der Luft und guckt, ob Paparazzi-Journalie-Drohnen da am Start sind.
Sind solche Dinge eigentlich, wir haben jetzt viel über öffentliche Einsätze gesprochen, also Polizei, Feuerwehr, Tralala, ist sowas auch schon irgendwie im journalistischen Bereich irgendwie aufgetaucht, dass jetzt genau das Beispiel Paparazzi irgendwelche Luxus-Villen von oben abfilmen mit so einem Ding?
Also ich hab's noch, mir ist noch nicht aufgefallen, aber es kann nicht mehr lange dauern. Also es wird sicherlich nicht mehr lange dauern.
Die fliegen doch schon mit Helikoptern rum, also warum dann nicht auch mit sowas?
Genau, also es kann sich nur noch um Monate handeln, denk ich mal so.
Ich glaub die effizienteste Methode, um sich momentan eine Micro-Drone zu holen, ist der stärkere Sender. Die sind nämlich in keiner Weise irgendwie geschützt, das ist ein ganz normales Fernsteuersystem, handelsüblich. Ich brauch einfach nur einen dickeren Endstufentransistor in meine Fernbedienung eingebaut und dann ist sie meiner.
Achso, weil du dann die Kontrolle überlegst?
Ja klar, der stärkste Träger gewinnt.
Und wenn sie niedrig fliegt, reicht das für eine Wasserpistole?
Ja genau, das wollte ich wissen. Wie autonom sind denn die Geschichten schon? Die haben schon immer noch so ein...
Also im Moment wird der GPS primär dazu verwendet, den stabil in der Luft zu halten?
Also könnte man quasi auch, wenn man jetzt nicht irgendwie die passende Fernsteuerung parat hat, so ein Störsender ist ja schnell gebaut.
Ja, wenn der Störsender greift, bleibt das Ding auf der Stelle stehen, bis der Akku alle ist und landet dann, wo er ist. Das ist so das Protokoll bei der Micro-Drone im Augenblick. Also die fallen nicht einfach runter? Die fallen nicht einfach runter. Das ist ein Luftnagel, der hat GPS. Wenn da irgendwas nicht stimmt, gibt es zwei Modi, die kann man einstellen. Der eine ist, bleib da, wo du bist, guck, ob du es wiederkriegst. Wenn nicht, lande. Und die andere Variante ist, fliegt genau die Strecke zurück, die du gekommen bist. Das ist dann schon sehr schwierig. Aber den stärkeren Sender zu haben, dann ist sie meine.
Also eine andere illegale Methode wäre halt, einen GPS-Jammer zu bauen. Das heißt, es ist ein Störsender, der das GPS-Signal stört. Das ist aber in Deutschland illegal. Man kann die zwar im Internet kaufen, aber wie gesagt, die Verwendung ist seit der Einführung der Autobahn-Maut illegal. Da darf man also das Navigationssignal von GPS nicht stören. Das würde aber auch dazu führen, dass im Zweifel die Drohne irgendwie entweder nicht mehr stabil fliegt oder abhaut.
Und gibt es da schon irgendwelche Verschlüsselungstechniken? Oder ist das, also ich kann mir das gar nicht vorstellen.
Bei dem Mikrodrohnen nicht, nein.
Nee, aber es wird halt nicht mehr lange dauern, also bei den meteorischen Drohnen sind die Steuerprotokolle alle verschlüsselt und gehärtet.
Gut Hannes, wir hoffen, wir haben jetzt deinen kleinen Rucksack gepackt, sollst du dir morgen eine Drohne über den Weg fliegen, dass du genau weißt, was du da tust. Erst Wink und dann Wasserzister.
Genau, also ansonsten kann man natürlich auch noch irgendwie, keine Ahnung, so was wie Tonmummel mit der Zwille oder so was ausprobieren.
Ja, da muss man aber schon gut mit der Zwille.
Das ist mir ein paar Spaßfüllen. Patrick ist am Telefon, danke dir Hannes.
Ich hab eine Idee, wie man das machen kann. Und zwar gibt es da, wenn ihr bei Google eingibt, Thumbmobile Zapper, gibt es einen Heiseartikel, wie man aus einer Mikrowelle das mal mit einem Neutron nimmt und mit einer Satellitenschüssel gegen den gewünschten Gegenstand richtet und das Ding einfach mal kaputt macht.
Das ist auch nicht so gänzlich legal.
Nee, nicht so richtig.
Wieso, wenn die von meinem Haus fliegt, die Drohne? Auf meinem Grundstück.
Also das Problem ist halt eher, dass du eine Mikrowelle umzubauen, also da sozusagen, das ist halt, nun sagen wir, ich würde das nicht empfehlen für den Hausgebrauch.
Nee, das würde ich auch nicht empfehlen.
Also so ein Mangetron kann halt relativ schnell zur Erhitzung von wasserhaltigen Körperteilen auf relativ hohe Temperaturen führen.
Das ist so, ich mein, man kann auch Sprengstoff selber bauen und diverse, man kann auch versuchen, mit einer Kartoffelkanone nach der Drohne zu schießen.
Ja, man kann auch versuchen, sich Knopper in die Backe zu nähen und Klavier dran zu hängen. Genau.
Oder so lange dran drehen, bis Radio Luxemburg kommt.
Das wollen wir. Das Ding ist aber auf jeden Fall kaputt. Die Kippen sind da drin gebraten.
Nee, du kannst, also mal so eine Drohne gegen 2, 4 GHz Abtischung ist relativ trivial. Du brauchst eigentlich dazu nur im Wesentlichen das Gehäuse von Metalllack sprühen und an die größte Metallstelle an dem Gehäuse füllen. Genau, das ist halt relativ trivial zu machen. Gerade bei meteorischen Drohnen ist das auch total üblich. Die werden halt gegen EMP gehärtet. Also da gewinnt man nicht so viel, außer Ärger mit den Nachbarn.
Siehst du, Patrick, also auch du mit einer Wasserpistole einfach.
Wasserpistole und Laser, ja.
Genau, also Laser gegen die Kamera blenden, das ist im Zweifel das Einfassende.
Am Telefon ist Christian. Hallo Christian, grüß dich.
Ja, hallo.
Der erste heute Abend, der nicht hurra schreit, wenn wir über Drohnen reden.
Ja, genau. Wie gesagt, also ich verfolge die Sendung durch Zufall, weil ich hier oben in dem Raum am Arbeiten bin bei euch, komme eigentlich aus der Koblenzerkante unten. Und wie gesagt, bin total schockiert, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, über das Thema, wo ihr da sprecht, dass das überhaupt schon so akut ist, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, bin ich total baff. Also ich wusste zwar, dass es so welche gibt und dass so etwas auch verwendet wird, vielleicht im militärischen Bereich, aber dass da im privaten Bereich schon im Prinzip spioniert wird mit den Dingern und so weiter, also ist für mich absolut neu, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen.
Du musst mal gucken im Internet, Mikrokopter, also Mikro mit K und Kopter auch mit k.com oder.de. Da gibt es sogar ein Video, wie die so ein Ding starten. Also so ein kleines Modellflugzeug, starten die aus der Hand und dann kannst du mit der Kamera sehen, was die Drohne alles sieht. Du hast echt das Gefühl, du sitzt im Fernsehen.
Also wie gesagt, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, ich hab von dem ganzen technischen Kram da mit der Drohne keine Ahnung, muss ich ganz ehrlich dazu sagen. Ich bin so ein Computerfreak nicht, muss ich sagen, aber ich bin total schockiert. Dass die im Prinzip so verwendet werden, sind den ganzen Kram schon im privaten Bereich.
Jetzt noch mal die Frage an die Experten, um den Einwand von Christian aufzugreifen. Wir haben jetzt eineinhalb Stunden schon über Drohnen geredet. Wie dramatisch oder akut ist diese Thematik jetzt wirklich im normalen privaten Leben?
Momentan haben wir keine Ahnung, wie viele Leute werden es vielleicht in Deutschland gebaut haben? 150 oder was?
Ja, insgesamt, aber geh mal davon aus, dass zwei Drittel das entweder nicht fertig gekriegt haben oder nicht mehr interessiert.
Oder es irgendwie gegen den nächsten Baum geflogen haben. Die Fakt ist, es geht. Also es geht. Deswegen, wir reden ja immer gerne relativ früh über Technik, wenn sie halt absehbar wird, dass es kommt, dann kann man rechtzeitig drüber nachdenken. Es ist jetzt noch nicht so, dass du jetzt damit rechnen musst, dass der Nachbar schon so ein Ding über deinen Pool fliegt. Das wäre sehr unwahrscheinlich. Aber es abzusehen, dass es nicht mehr lange dauern kann, bis es bei Chibo eine China-Drohne für 200 Euro gibt, die genau diese totet. Es kann sich maximal nach zwei Jahren handeln bis die Technologie soweit ist. Deswegen reden wir darüber, um darauf aufmerksam zu machen, was schon heute geht und in naher Zukunft passieren wird.
Und wo die unterschiedlichen Problematiken sind. Und wenn du anrufst Christian und sagst, ich wusste nicht, dass es soweit ist, ist vielleicht damit schon eins der Ziele dieser Sendung erreicht, nämlich überhaupt mal darüber zu reden, dass es Dinge auf dieser Welt gibt.
Absolut richtig. Ich bin total begeistert von der Sendung. Kann man nicht anders sagen.
Allerdings.
Danke dir für deinen Anruf, Christian. Und falls ihr gerade reingeschaltet habt und die gesamte Sendung nochmal hören wollt, überhaupt kein Problem. Es gibt davon ein Podcast, einfach chaosradio.ccc.de. Wir machen jetzt die Nachrichten und danach reden wir weiter über Drohnen.
Lauschen wir nun einer Kurzbotschaft der Beatstakes. Sensation! Grande Finale! Fritz präsentiert das Berlin-Konzert der Beatstakes live im Radio. Das ausverkaufte Tour-Finale der Beatstakes live im Fritz-Radio-Konzert. Freitag, 29.
fritz.de Und?
Die allerletzten Tickets zum Live-Dabei sein haben wir auch noch. Einfach gut fritz hören. Das ausverkaufte Berlin-Konzert der Beatstakes live im Radio. Freitag, 29.
Nach dem Absturz einer Passagiermaschine auf dem Flughafen von Madrid wird die Zahl der Toten immer weiter nach oben korrigiert. Wie die Regionalregierung in Madrid mitteilte, kamen 153 Menschen ums Leben. 19 seien schwer verletzt worden. Ein Sprecher sagte, an Bord der Unglücksmaschine seien 172 Personen gewesen. Rangaben der Fluggesellschaft Lufthansa könnten auch Deutsche unter den Opfern sein. Für den Flug der Spanischen Gesellschaft Spanair hätten auch vier Deutsche eingecheckt. Die Maschine war unmittelbar nach dem Start in Richtung Gran Canaria zerschellt. Im Georgien-Konflikt verschärft sich der Ton zwischen der Europäischen Union und Russland. Der französische Außenminister und EU-Ratsvorsitzende Kuschner warf Präsident Medvedev Wortbruch vor. Ein größerer Abzug russischer Truppen aus Georgien sei nach wie vor nicht erkennbar. Das sei eine Missachtung internationaler Vereinbarungen, die so nicht hingenommen werden könne, so Kuschner. Medvedev hatte sich vertraglich zum Rückzug der Truppen verpflichtet. Er soll bis Freitagnacht abgeschlossen sein. Bis dahin will die NATO ihre militärische Zusammenarbeit mit Russland ruhen lassen. Die Bundesregierung will die Bürger besser vor Handy-Strahlung schützen. Umweltminister Gabriel kündigte dazu einen Gesetzentwurf an. Die Mobilfunkstrahlung nehme zu. Darauf müsse die Politik reagieren, sagten Gabriel und der Präsident des Bundesamts für Strahlenschutz König bei der Vorstellung des Strahlenschutzjahresberichts. Zur Abwehr von Hautkrebs durch künstliche UV-Strahlen bekräftigte Gabriel die Absicht, Minderjährigen und Jugendlichen den Besuch von Sonnenstudios zu verbieten. Beide Vorhaben sollen in das neue Umweltgesetzbuch aufgenommen werden. Start! Die deutsche Fußball-Nationalmannschaft hatte Nürnberg ihr erstes Testspiel nach der Europameisterschaft 2 zu 0 gegen Belgien gewonnen. Bastian Schweinsteiger verwandelte in der 59. Minute einen faul 11 Meter und in der 77. Minute traf Marco Marin für Deutschland. Heute Nacht ist es meist trocken bei Tiefstwerten bis 12 Grad. Am Tag dann ein Wechsel aus Sonne und Wolken, dabei nur selten kurzer Schauer. Die Höchstwerte liegen bei 25 Grad. A2 Berlin Richtung Magdeburg. Zwischen Brandenburg an der Havel und Voliden gibt es Gefahr durch einen defekten LKW, da ist die rechte Spur und die Anstoßstelle Voliden blockiert. Stadtverkehr Berlin A100 der Stadtring Richtung Wedding am Tempelhofer Damm ist die Ausfahrt gesperrt und wird gebaut. Es ist aber eine Umleitung eingerichtet. Sonst überall gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 101, 5? Dann Fritz in Eisenhüttenstadt.
Blum, die zwei Sprechstunden. Chaosradio, wir reden über Drohnen, kurze Gorillas und dann gehts weiter. In Chaos Radio auf Fritz, Nummer 138. Frank-Ri-Gon Steini sind hier, wir reden über Drohnen und wir hatten gerade eine lange ausführliche Diskussion darüber, ob man sich da jetzt Sorgen machen muss oder auch nicht. Mit der Frage, ich wusste gar nicht, dass die Entwicklung bei Drohnen schon so weit ist. Wir hatten ja auch erwähnt, dass Drohnen mittlerweile für relativ schmalen Trailer als Bausatz auch zu kriegen sind. Wie ist denn da ansonsten in der Welt der Roboter der Stand der technischen Entwicklung? Was kommt da noch? Was dazu, Frank?
Was momentan läuft, ist primär das, was man vielleicht als Telepräsenz bezeichnen könnte. Das heißt also, die Autonomie dieser Systeme beschränkt sich im Wesentlichen darauf, dass sie eben erstmal von selber irgendwo gegenfliegen oder zumindest irgendwie einen Punkt erreichen von selbst, aber doch immer noch ein Operator mit dabei ist. Also dass die Dinger selbstständig komplette Missionen fliegen, ist noch nicht der Fall. Genauso ist es auch bei den Bodenbewegten Systemen wie zum Beispiel diesen Wachroboter nicht der Fall. Die sind halt erstmal Verlängerungen der Sinne des Menschen. Also sie können halt deine Sinne irgendwo hin transportieren, wo du gerade nicht sein kannst oder willst. Das hat auch schon eine sehr lange Tradition, also Bombenentschaffungsroboter, die Dinger, die sie in Kernkraftwerken einsetzen, wenn sie da den Scheiß aufräumen müssen, nach Tscharnobyl zum Beispiel oder bei Chemieunfällen und so. Solche Sachen gibt es ja schon sehr lange und die werden aber gewinnen immer mehr an Autonomität. Das heißt, die können immer mehr Dinge selber tun, um die du dich dann nicht drum kümmern musst. Dann einfach sagen kannst, fahr mal den Flur runter und dann fährt der Ding den Flur runter und fährt von selber um und fährt Schutthaufen drum rum. Das sind halt so die, also da wird halt sehr viel Energie reingesteckt, weil dafür sehr viele praktische Anwendungsfälle gibt. Und was ich schon erwarte ist, dass sowas zum Beispiel verwendet werden kann, dass du körperlich irgendwo anwesend sein kannst, wo du gerade nicht hinfliegen willst. Also dass es zum Beispiel einen Roboter gibt, der dich auf einer Konferenz vertritt. Der kann erstmal im Rollstuhl sitzen, weil dafür ist die Welt mittlerweile auch eingerichtet, zumindest im Westen. Oder vielleicht später kann er auf zwei Beinen laufen und hat halt irgendwie eine Projektion von dem Gesicht reingeklebt und kann für dich halt Hände schütteln auf einer Konferenz, wo du gerade nicht anwesend sein kannst. So eine Anwendung wird es relativ viele, denke ich mal auch relativ bald geben. Dann ist sicherlich dieser ganze Bereich mehr so Haushaltshilfen, Krankentransport, Exoskelette, das ist auch so ein Ding, ist ja de facto so ein Roboter, denke da wird sehr viel passieren. Also weil so ein Exoskelett ist eine Sache, die wollen wir eigentlich alle haben. Wenn wir irgendwie 70 und klapprig sind, dann wollen wir trotzdem noch irgendwie selber die Treppen hoch gehen können. Das heißt, wir wollen halt einen Iron Man Style.
Du ziehst ja quasi so einen Anzug an, der für dich, die dich bei den Bewegungen unterstützt.
Genau, ich setze mich in einen Roboter, der im Prinzip meine Außenhülle stabilisiert und mit Kraft versieht.
Also in dem Bereich gibt es ja speziell in Japan schon eine Menge Entwicklungen, wo es um Reha-Technik und Reha-Roboter geht. Da sind die ja sehr fit.
Genau, da machen die eine ganze Menge, einfach bedingt durch die bealtrohende Gesellschaft und ihren Hightech-Filmen, denen sie ohnehin haben, sodass die Einsatzschwelle relativ gering. Dann ist eine ganze Menge passiert im Bereich Spezialanwendung, Fensterputzroboter auf großen Glasflächen, Staubsauger-Roboter.
Da fährt doch einer am Hauptbahnhof über die Glasflächen.
Genau, da fährt so ein Ding vielleicht darüber.
Wer ist jetzt verantwortlich, wenn der Runde fällt?
Ja, interessante Frage. Ich glaube, er ist festgeputt. Na gut, da fällt noch ein anderer Stahlträger.
Kann man da mit einer Drohne hinfahren und den einfach einsacken? Achso, dann brauchst du eine Schraubdohne.
Da muss ich überhaupt kurz mal Fensterputzroboter, da muss ich eine Story loswerden. Da war ich so platt, da war irgendwo so ein unbedeutender und so ein kleines Artikel über den Entwicklung, dass sie elektrostatische Adhessionen jetzt irgendwie mal in richtig gemacht haben. Das ist jetzt kurz ein bisschen technisch. Die haben im Prinzip eine Folie genommen, legen da massiv Spannung an und jeder kennt das, wenn man so einen Luftballon am Pulli reibt, dann klebt der an der Decke. Was ich nicht wusste, was wir dann aber mal nachrecherchiert haben, man kann tatsächlich mit der Energie aus einer AA, einer Mignon-Zelle, kann man genug Elektroadhession erzeugen um 100 Kilo an die Decke zu hängen. Da war ich richtig platt.
Also die haben jetzt Roboter gebaut, die können Wände hochgehen.
Und zwar ganz gleich, was das für ein Material ist. Aufgrund dieser Elektroadhession, genau. Auf dieser elektrostatischen Adhession. Da war ich richtig platt.
Wenn du sagst, die bauen sowas, wer ist und wer baut sowas?
Das sind meistens jetzt irgendwelche universitären Entwicklungen. Ich bin unsicher, es kam irgendwie aus den USA. Ich hab's jetzt nicht mehr, es ist schon ein bisschen her.
Was man jetzt schon kaufen kann im privaten Bereich, sind diese Staubsaugerroboter.
Die durch deine Wohnung fahren und dann vor dem Aquarium umdrehen und wieder zurückfahren.
Genau, die sind halt noch ein bisschen laut, aber ansonsten funktionieren die eigentlich ganz gut. Der Staubbeutel ist ein bisschen kleiner.
Aber, und das war der echte Durchbruch letztlich, die finden jetzt ihre Basisstation wieder und können sich selber wieder aufladen.
Genau, also du musst die nicht mehr irgendwie...
Das ist das, was du vorhin sagtest, nimm eine Drohne und sag ihr bitte, du fährst zur Aufladestation und fliegst wieder über Bodentau.
Das ist der nächste Schritt, weil momentan haben wir 15 Minuten mit so einer Drohne, das reicht für nichts. Außer mal eben schnell kurz gucken. Was man will ist, die haben eine Stunde Ladezeit, 20 Minuten Flugzeit, ich hab drei Stück, es ist immer einer in der Luft, und zwar ohne, dass ich mich kümmere. Dazu reicht es ja, dass sie immer über meinem Haus schwebt und sich langsam im Kreis dreht und ein Überwachungsturm spielt, sagen wir mal, und dann wieder landet und dann kommt die, also auch keine komplexe Bewegung, aber das wird in aller nächster Zukunft kommen, das haben wir noch nächstes Jahr.
Eine Idee, was man noch machen kann, hat Jorg zum Beispiel angerufen, 0331 77 97 110, hallo Jorg.
Ja, ich hab letztes Jahr bei eurer Blumen-Sendung zu Drohnen mich schon mal ein bisschen beteiligt. Ganz witzig, eigentlich komme ich selten dazu, Blumen zu hören, aber wenn ihr euch über Drohnen unterhaltet, läuft es mir immer über den Weg. Ja, also ich wollte mal dazu sagen, ihr habt ja jetzt viel darüber geredet, was Drohnen so für Gefahren bedeuten könnten in Zukunft oder was ist für den einzelnen für Einschränkungen dadurch.
Na, wir haben nur versucht, diese allgemeine Hurra-Thematik ein bisschen zu korrigieren.
Ja, aber das Problem, was ich dabei sehe, oder beziehungsweise den Punkt, den ich dabei sehe, ist, dass man heutzutage eigentlich durch Handys, durch Internet etc. PP, also dadurch, dass heutzutage eigentlich alles digitalisiert abläuft, was man früher halt per Hand gemacht hat, man ja schon viel überwachter ist, als es so eine Drohne heutzutage, also zumindest im zivilen Bereich, jetzt für den Bürger leisten könnte.
Aber das ist halt ein Baustein mehr, ne? Der Punkt ist halt, man kann es halt nicht gegeneinander abwägen. Es ist ja nicht so, dass jetzt dadurch, dass es Drohnen gibt, ist die Internetüberwachung weg. Sondern es ist halt so, dass der Baustein dazukommt, dass auf der Basis der Position, die zum Beispiel aus dem Mobiltelefon zu erzählen ist, dass es sehr einfach ist, eine Drohne zu schicken, die dich dann auch noch föhnt.
Genau, aber dazu muss man ja im Prinzip schon im Visier sein. Also was schon eine Drohne im Prinzip macht, ist, wenn irgendwo ein Verdacht ist, wenn die Einsatzkräfte oder wer auch immer das Ding jetzt verwendet, jetzt in irgendeiner Form noch ein weiteres Werkzeug braucht, um jetzt sagen wir mal ihre Arbeit zu tun, oder was auch immer sie da tun. Also wir leben ja zum Glück nicht in einem Überwachungsstaat, wie zu DDR-Zeiten. Sodass man eigentlich schon davon ausgehen kann, dass damit verantwortungsvoll umgegangen wird.
Was veranlasst dich dazu? Also wo kommt diese Theorie her, dass damit verantwortungsvoll umgegangen wird?
Das ist jetzt keine Theorie, sondern das ist einfach meine Beobachtung unserer heutigen Gesellschaft, dass einfach in der Bundesrepublik, also ich muss dazu sagen, ich bin aus dem Osten, mit Daten, solange sie zumindest öffentlich gehandhabt werden, oder auch eben mit solchen Mitteln wie Drohnen, oder was die Polizei oder sonst die Einsatzkräfte eben sonst an Möglichkeiten haben, um jetzt dem Bürger in irgendeiner Form zu schaden, dass das schon verantwortungsvoll eingesetzt wird.
Du hast den aktuellen Skandal komplett nicht mitgekriegt.
Der aktuelle Skandal handelt erst mal kommerzielle Sachen.
Ja und was glaubst du, wo die Informationen alle herkommen?
Die kommen von Callcentern, das hat ja jetzt zum Beispiel mit Polizei oder Feuerwehr etc.
Nein, natürlich und es gab auch noch nie den Fall, dass der Konsul des Schwagers, der bei der Polizei ist, dann mal eben schnell rausgefunden hat, für wen diese Autonummer da ist. Also ein ganz heikles Thema.
Ich möchte mich jetzt ehrlich gar nicht so in diese Richtung mit der Diskussion bewegen, weil wir immer schon mal kurz dabei sind, dass ich kenne auch Polizisten und die sagen, wenn sie ein Autokennzeichen ermitteln wollen, dann brauchen die einen Fall dazu. Das kann man nicht einfach so machen. Wir sind ein sehr bürokratischer Staat, da wird immer überall versucht, entsprechende Netze einzuziehen, dass eben so ein Klügel nicht entstehen kann. Vorgebeugt wird, natürlich kann man es nicht immer verhindern, aber es wird nicht flächendechend gemacht. Wir befinden uns nicht in einem Staat.
Die Frage ist folgende. Warum dann weigern sich die Innenminister standhaft, polizeiliche Maßnahmen, die genehmigt werden, entweder zeitlich zu begrenzen oder wissenschaftlich zu evaluieren?
Ein Innenminister ist ein Politiker, den würde ich da jetzt nicht...
Nein, nein, nein, das sind auch so Leute wie z.B. der BKA-Präsident, der weigert sich und sagt, wir gewollen keine wissenschaftliche Evaluation, weil wir sonst möglicherweise die politische Rückendeckung verlieren. Weil bei dieser Evaluation z.B. rauskommt, dass die Polizei ihren Benachrichtigungspflichten bei Bewachungsmaßnahmen nicht mal einem Drittel der Fälle nachkommt. Weil z.B. dabei rauskommt, dass bei Telefonüberwachung, im Gegensatz zu vielen anderen Ländern, keine Ermittlungen stattfindet, wie erfolgreich das eigentlich ist. Also in wie viel Prozent der Fälle tatsächlich z.B. eine Verurteilung kommt. Ja, es gibt es nicht, weil es wird politisch verweigert. Und aus diesem Grund bin ich enorm skeptisch, dass damit verantwortlich umgegangen wird.
Ich habe kein Problem damit, dass man skeptisch ist. Das ist auch immer gut, man muss die Sachen natürlich hinterfragen. Aber auf der anderen Seite muss man natürlich auch sehen, welche Möglichkeiten, und auch im positiven Sinne, betrachtet jetzt Drohnen eben nicht nur für die Polizei, sondern eben auch für kommerziellen Einsatz. Also wenn es um, keine Ahnung, Hochspannungsleitungen überwacht. Oder Waldbrände früher entdecken, alles solche Sachen. Also man kann mit Drohnen unheimlich viel anfangen, was man heutzutage natürlich, wenn man es denn machen will, sehr teuer mit bemanter Luftfahrt machen muss.
Na ja, oder mit allen anderen Sachen. Das haben wir auch gerade angeschnitten, dass die Drohne einfach im Zweifelsfall, oder das unbemannte Objekt, welches auch immer, einfach dahin gehen kann, wo Menschenleben in Gefahr sind. Also was weiß ich, irgendwelche Katastrophenherde oder Unfallgeschichten.
Obwohl es nur der seltenste Fall ist, aber oft hat man halt eben, dass man Sachen, wo man wirklich jetzt Sachen, die jetzt keinen persönlichen Schaden, wie zum Beispiel Weitbrennen oder sonst was macht.
Jaja, so hatten wir alles, haben wir aber eingangs ja auch diskutiert. Der Architekt, der eben seine Baustelle auch mal anguckt.
Ich habe jetzt eure Sendung nicht von anderen verfolgt.
Da fehlt dir jetzt genau dieser Teil.
Ist klar, ist überhaupt auch nicht schlimm. Wir wollten ja auch hier nicht sagen, dass Drohnen böse böse böse sind, sondern einfach nur darauf hinweisen, wie weit die technische Entwicklung schon ist, dass du so ein Ding für unter 1000 Euro bauen kannst und los schicken kannst und wohin die technische Entwicklung dann noch geht und welche Pros und Contras da links und rechts vom Wege liegen, das können wir hier in der 2-Stunden-Sendung natürlich gar nicht anreißen.
Die Pros gerade jetzt von der Tatsache, dass die Drohne jetzt auch beim Mikrokopter und so weiter und so fort immer günstiger und einfacher wird, sehe ich einfach, dass sie nicht mehr ausschließlich militärisch genutzt wird. Weil militärische Nutzung ist immer dann, wenn das Militär quasi für viele Millionen, die können ja mit einem Heidengeld darin versenken, quasi eine Technologie für sich allein nutzen kann.
Jetzt kommt gleich wahrscheinlich die Theorie mit der Teflon-Fanne und der Raumfahrt.
Also für uns ist halt das Problem, dass wenn so neue Technologie anfängt, in Benutzung zu kommen, dann muss man sich halt darüber Gedanken machen, benötigt das eine Regulierung? Wenn ja, wie soll die aussehen? Natürlich, klar. Also ist es z.B. notwendig, bei den Modellflugzeugen oder besseren Modellflugzeugen mit GPS und einer Kamera unten dran, sind wir vermutlich noch nicht in dem Bereich, wo man sagt, ok, da braucht man eine Regulierung, wenn die Dinge aber plötzlich wirklich in großen Massen eingesetzt werden können, weil sie enorm billig geworden sind. Und wenn du einfach mal, als nur Spaß halber annimmst, du könntest einfach 1000 von den Dingern permanent über Berlin in der Luft haben.
Das geht ja nun gerade bei den Mikrokoptern um, die sicher sagen, wenn wir diese Theorie über Berlin haben, dann sagen wir, wir bewegen uns im elektrischen Bereich unter 5 Kilo, das sind dann diese Mikrodrohnen, die können ja nun nicht länger als 20 Minuten in der Luft bleiben.
Das ist vollkommen in Ordnung, wenn du 5000 Stück hast, dann hast du 2500 auf der Leiterstadt und 2500 an der Luft. Also wir müssen einfach darüber nachdenken, wie sehen so eine Szenarien aus?
Das wäre im Prinzip genau das Gleiche, wenn es schon heute darum geht, wer da seine Filiale auf der Straße, Bankfiliale oder was auch immer, mit einer Kamera wie weit überwachen, ohne dass er Persönlichkeitsrechte verlässt.
Genau, da gibt es eben diese Thematik.
Im Prinzip ist das ja schon abgedeckt, wenn man so will. Weil dazu gibt es Rechtsprechung, damit wurde sich befasst. Und eine Drohne ist ja nichts weiter als eine sich bewegende Kamera. Deshalb muss man es letztendlich nur auf die Drohne übertragen.
Genau, nur montan passiert das halt noch nicht. Das sind halt so die Dinge, die uns da bewegen. Und pauschal zu sagen, ich vertraue unseren Ermittlungsbehörden, weil bisher haben sie keinen Scheiß gebaut. Ne, so blöd bin ich nicht.
Nein, so wollte ich das auch nicht verstanden wissen. Ich wollte nur sagen, dass man eben auch sehen muss, dass diese Drohne eben auch sehr nützlich ist. Auch in der Hand der Polizei, selbst wenn wir nicht immer der Polizei vertrauen wollen.
Unbestritten, ja.
Ja, das war im Prinzip mein Beitrag dazu.
Alles klar, danke dir viermals.
Danke auch, tschüss.
Wir haben auch eine Mail bekommen, die wollen wir nicht vorenhalten. Und zwar von Lars. Der hat geschrieben, er kann sich ganz gut vorstellen, dass es bald selbstverständlich ist, mit Drohnen zu leben. Wenn die Technik erstmal so klein ist durch die Nanotechnologie, werden die auch nur noch verschwindend klein sein. Er findet das Thema sehr spannend, schön. Gruß Lars. Also, eine Menge passiert. Auf jeden Fall konnten wir wahrscheinlich die ganze Thematik von wegen Drohnen und autonome Geräte heute nur im Bruchteil anreißen. Aber wir haben wahrscheinlich beleuchtet, wie weit die technische Entwicklung ist. Und euch den einen oder anderen Gedankenansatz dazu mitgegeben. Jetzt ist es, glaube ich, nochmal Zeit, über die Motodrone zu reden.
Sollen wir unbedingt nochmal machen?
Sollten wir machen und wir sollten auch noch da sagen, dass es Chaosradio Express gibt.
Genau, Chaosradio Express.
Genau, also Chaosradio Express wird noch eine Chaosradio Express-Sendung zu dem ganzen Drohnen-Thema geben, die ein bisschen mehr auch in die Technik reingeht. Also ein bisschen erklärt, wie funktioniert es eigentlich mit diesen Kreimanfiltern, den Sensoren, den Brasch-Lassmotoren und so weiter. Diese ganzen Dinge wird vermutlich sogar noch vor der Motodrohne passieren, weiß ich aber nicht ganz genau. Ansonsten gibt es seit der letzten Sendung vier neue Chaosradio Express-Podcasts zum Runterladen unter chaosradio.ccc.de. Ich habe jetzt die Themen nicht alle im Kopf, aber es sah irgendwie ganz interessant aus. Klickt da mal drauf, ladet euch die runter. Chaosradio Express ist sozusagen die Ergänzung zum Chaosradio hier auf Fritz.
Der technische große Bruder.
Wo halt einfach die technischen Dinge ein bisschen mehr ausführlich gewürdigt werden können. Ja, ansonsten wie gesagt chaosradio.ccc.de, da gibt es halt auch noch mehr Details und Informationen dann.
Genau, und auch den Podcast dieser Sendung.
Genau, und am 20. September ist die Veranstaltung Motodrone veranstaltet von dem Motodrone REV. Und damit arbeitet das Chaos Computer Clubs und etlichen anderen Institutionen. Paparazzi werden da sein, etliche Mikrokopter-Bauer werden da sein. Ich hoffe, jemand von Microdrones wird auch da sein. Hab ich noch nicht erreicht. Etliche Vertreter von Politik und Wissenschaft werden anwesend sein. Wir werden Mikrokopter live und zum Zugucken dort bauen. Wir werden den Stand der Entwicklung für die Challenges, die eigentlich hätten stattfinden sollen, zu denen aber fast alle Bewerber einfach nicht so weit sind, dass sie die Aufgaben hätten lösen können. Wir werden dort einfach den Stand der Technik diskutieren, den Stand der Entwicklung diskutieren, gegenseitig Hilfestellungen geben, den neuen Termin für die Challenges besprechen, an den es dann tatsächlich wirklich um die Wurst geht. Macht keinen Sinn, wenn da jetzt zwei Leute gegeneinander antreten und beide das Problem irgendwie mehr schlecht als recht lösen. Das wäre schade, so ist es nicht gedacht. Deswegen, grob wird die eigentliche Challenge im nächsten Jahr stattfinden. Wir schätzen Mai oder Juni, sodass also auch der Chaos Communication Kongress noch dazwischen liegt, um eben sich wieder zu treffen, noch mal Update zu haben, noch mal konkret miteinander dran zu arbeiten. Die Veranstaltung wird stattfinden, wie schon gesagt, am 20. September in Finofort, Furt auf dem alten Militärflughafen Museum. Das ist nördlich von Bernau, noch die Autobahn hoch Wandlitz vorbei, Lanker vorbei.
So eine Dreiviertelstunde von Berlin.
Genau, 50 Kilometer etwa. www.motodrone.org www.motodrone.org, genau, da findet ihr auch alle notwendigen Informationen und wir freuen uns total, wenn ihr zahlreich kommt. Mitdiskutiert, mitbastelt, euch das einfach anschaut oder da einen schönen Tag verbringt. Da diskutieren wir drüber. Ich glaube ja, aber nicht viel. Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht mehr, was wir genau gesagt haben.
Das ist rauszukriegen motodrone.org 20. September. Ansonsten chaosradio.ccc.de Da gibt es die Podcasts der Sendungen und auch alle anderen Sendungen aus der Vergangenheit noch mal zu nachhören. Da gibt es die Chaosradio Expresses. Hier gibt es nicht mehr viel zu sagen, außer passt auf, dass ihr nicht über eine Drohne stolpert. Danke für das Anrufen, danke für das Mitdiskutieren und danke für diese höchst interessante Sendung, in der wir alle ein bisschen was gelernt haben. Frank Rier und Steini vom CCC waren hier. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz. Wir machen jetzt uns vom Acker, weil hier kommen Maxwell Smart und seine komischen Beat-Bastler. Alles klar, Maxwell und seine DJs sind am Start. Die sind in 5 Minuten im Neustart für euch da. Wir sagen Tschüss bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss von mir und bastelt schön und lasst euch nicht unterkriegen.